what's happening to our country whether
it's the borders or the elections or
kinds of things like this where the doj
has become a weapon for the Democrats an
absolute weapon and it seems that every
time my polls you know we're leading by
a lot and we're leading by a lot in a
place called Iowa a lot
and
not only were there
by a tremendous amount they haven't seen
anything like it and they feel I guess
they want to try and demean and diminish
and and frighten people but they don't
frighten us because we're going to make
America great again that's all there is
we're going to make our our country
our country John is a mess you know it
better than anybody I mean frankly your
reporting is incredible I'll be honest I
have never been more fearful of the
state of this country than I am right
now fearful about the economy foreign
policy our future our kids our grandkids
I've never been this way well you look
at Biden with these leaders and they're
at the top of their game and they're
looking at each other like they don't
even believe what's happening our
country is no longer respected think of
it three years ago energy independent
powerful military that was totally
rebuilt the president announced three
days ago which he should never have said
probably classified information that we
have no ammunition now what do you think
China says when they hear we have no
ammunition uh no it's a very very sad
thing if you look at the worst Border in
history we had the best Border in
history we had three years ago the best
border we've ever had we built hundreds
of miles of wall we got Mexico free of
charge you know they say about Mexico
Mexico gave us billions of dollars worth
of soldiers for years 28 000 soldiers
guarding our border we had the best
numbers we've ever had today we have I
think the worst numbers in the world
because I don't think there's any
country in the world that would stand
for what's happening to us with millions
of people flowing in from by the way
mental institutions insane asylums they
don't like me using those names insane
asylums but we have very bad very sick
people very ill people coming into our
country prisons and jails all over the
world and it's not the four countries
that we sort of consider neighbors it's
all over last week we had 129 countries
representatives of people that came into
our country illegally and we're losing
our country and we're losing the spirit
of our country but I will tell you make
America great again and Maga and America
First and all of these things that we
talk about there's never been more
Spirit look at this crowd there's never
been more Spirit than we have right now
okay
is the most important election that
we've ever had and I used to say it with
2016 and I meant it 100 but we're now
we're going into an almost a communistic
state and I think maybe we're even there
when you look at what they're doing with
you could call it fascist you could call
it Marxist you could call it Communists
what they're doing like with the
Department of Justice they've totally
weaponized it it's weaponized like we've
never had this before it's not only me
Catholics you see what's happening uh
parents at school boards they're being
harassed by the justice department by
the FBI nobody's ever seen what's
happening right now
and we have a guy the head of this
country it's it's probably not him it's
people around him they have people that
are vicious
and smart and have horrible ideas for
our country so it's really the people in
my opinion because I don't think this
guy can put together two sentences I
watched him last night
he's almost
who's almost incapable of talking and
you know we have I'm not I'm not sure he
knows today's Tuesday sir well we have a
we have a problem we have the potential
of a war beyond the war
with Russia and Ukraine and that would
have never happened before by the way if
I were president that would have never
happened if I were president Ukraine and
Russia I want to get
to that you know I came here today and I
I watched all I watched it two hours
with Mark Levin I watched our Tucker I
watch our
um uh Brett Bear you did two hours with
me I watched you on Maria I see I watch
your interviews and I on fake news CNN
um I watched that too well that was a
good one that wasn't good they had a
talent Hall that was a trump thing they
ended up firing the head of CNN because
and they get the highest ratings in 11
years and they fire it's supposed to be
the app by the way you might want to
start a show and at the end of every
show say to somebody you're fired that
would work right yes uh all right but I
wanted to talk about the problems and
the Solutions in other words what are
the identify the problems in the
solution we cannot ignore today's events
today when you put out your your true
social post and by that I want to talk
about what is clearly now what the
Judiciary Committee under Jim Jordan is
looking into whether or not our FBI and
our department of justice have been
weaponized and politicized and I have
two headlines here you know FBI tipped
off Biden team Secret Service about plan
to interview Hunter according to a
supervisory agent who retired tomorrow
there will be another IRS whistleblower
just like this man Mr chapley who came
out and said no he should have been
indicted on felony charges and I'm been
doing this meeting Hunter Biden that I
can take you back and you know that I
covered this every single night and my
show was Vindicated on the issue of
trump Russia collusion that never
occurred the Durham report corroborated
at the Horowitz report it's a long way
of me asking this very simple basic
question and that is if you look at
Hillary Clinton and the way she was
treated no prosecutor would prosecute 33
000 subpoenaed emails deleted devices
destroyed then her dirty dossier and
that dossier was used to get four Pfizer
warrants and then you look at the FBI in
2019 they had Hunter Biden's laptop in
December of 2019. they verified it in
March of 2020 and yet FBI agents in the
months leading up to that election or
meeting with big tech companies telling
them according to Joel Roth the former
Twitter Integrity side head telling them
that it might be about Joe or hunter
that laptop story got censor third the
American people will deny the truth
about what would be a bombshell story
and by the way it still is censored
because they haven't really gotten into
the meat with all of the great reporting
done and this has been some great
reporting done generally speaking the
Press is fake it's fake and it's just a
horrible actually but there's still been
some great reporters and great reporting
done and you are at the lead you've been
incredible but when you look thank you
when you look at that they haven't even
gotten to the bottom of the laptop they
don't want to put the pictures in they
don't want to they have pictures in
there that anybody else that go away for
10 years
what happened to Hunter is he got a
traffic ticket other people are being
sentenced to many years in jail for
doing much less he got a traffic ticket
the only good thing is the people know
it's not going to happen it's just not
going to happen now uh Jim Jordan and
Jamie Comer these guys are doing a great
job but the problem is you find out the
crime but nothing happens with it
instead they go after you like for
example Hillary Clinton's home wasn't
raided Joe Biden's garage wasn't raided
the UPenn Center wasn't raided the
University of Delaware wasn't raided his
home beach home I don't know how he
affords a beach home on a senator's
salary that wasn't rated Hunter Biden
has is being protected obviously
cocaine in the White House 10-day
investigation they they they literally
interviewed nobody okay investigation's
over would that have happened in your
White House well well listen to this
even you mentioned the beach home well
the beach home had all these documents
in it right it was by by the Corvette
they're on the floor classified
documents no that's not the beach home
now the beach home was another place
this is also the beach and they had the
Corvette where they had the Corvette and
a tremendous amount of payment was made
for That Home by somebody to Joe Biden
and it was a big story for about one day
and then you don't hear about it anymore
it's incredible but when you look at the
documents all over the place whatever
happened to that one they go after me on
documents and I have the presidential
records act which is a big deal and the
presidential records Act is a is is an
act
why weren't their homes rated well let
me just tell you I'm protected by
Presidential records act and they come
up with this obscure crazy Theory a
Madman Theory this guy is a deranged
prosecutor who's had tremendous failures
all over the place he's a nasty horrible
human being they come after me now they
have Biden has many thousands I mean
he's got 2 000 almost 2 000 boxes of
documents they can't get to him because
the college or whatever that has them
doesn't want to give him but and he
probably told the college but more
importantly China gives millions of
dollars to UPenn that's where he has
some he's got them all over the place
and maybe worst of all he's got
documents in Chinatown in Chinatown many
many documents boxes of documents you
don't ever hear about this all you hear
about is Trump and I'm totally covered
by the presidential records act and also
by the Clinton Sox case you know what
that is that's what Clinton took out
tapes and it sucks and he put him in his
drawer and they sued him just on a very
civil basis and he ended up winning the
lawsuit and the judge said he can have
whatever he wants and that's called the
presidential record what about Sandy
Burger shoving documents down his pants
oh there are many instances of it but
especially when you're president and Joe
Biden wasn't president you're only
covered by the presidential records act
if you're President Joe Biden wasn't
president in fact Joe Biden was Senator
for many years and they've got a lot of
classified documents when he was Senator
and other Democrat Senators can't even
believe the fact that he has these
documents candy but they said I watched
Dick Durbin here's another Beauty I
watched Dick Durbin saying I can't
believe that he took them I couldn't he
couldn't even believe it so it's a very
it's a two-tier system but it's worse
than that it's a very corrupt system
okay so my my question to you is when
you see that Hillary had top secret
classified information and the
conclusion of Jim Comey no prosecutor
whatever prosecute 33 000 subpoenaed
emails deleted devices destroyed okay
then we have the FBI in early October of
2016 sent agents over the pond to meet
with Christopher Steele they offered him
a million dollars to to verify any part
of that to get jumped okay they couldn't
verify it then in late October even
though it wasn't verified they used that
according to Andrew McCabe Deputy FBI
director without that dirty dossier they
would never have gotten those fiso
warrants approved now they knew that
they couldn't verify it the dura report
confirmed none of it was true and yet
they would use that as a backdoor Aspire
in your campaign and your presidency is
that a dual system of justice and the
whole thing with Pfizer was horrible but
you know one thing we did that was so
great I fired Comey very early and a lot
of people said oh you should have done
it well you know they're giving a term
they'd give it a turn very early
not immediately early but very early
early in a few months and I got rid of
this guy and by doing that it was like
you threw a rock at a hornet's nest the
whole thing collapsed you saw the Love
Letters back and forth with the
different people talking about the
insurance policy you know what the
insurance policy that was against me
that was how to issue for some reason
loses darling we have an insurance
policy the insurance policies they'll
get me out one way or the other they'll
get me out because you know what this is
30 35 years of being put into government
and you get there and initially I didn't
know people in Washington I was there 17
times in my entire life I never stayed
over never stayed over before this all
of a sudden I'm president of the United
States I relate and we had tremendous
people also don't forget biggest tax
cuts in history biggest regulation Cuts
in history rebuilt our military took out
ices took out solomani took out Al
baghdadi and the two biggest terrorists
in the world I mean what we did was
incredible strongest border we've ever
had everything was good no inflation
best economy in history we did all of
this stuff we had tremendous we had
tremendous people look they made a lot
of money
no no so we had tremendous people but we
also had some you rely on others you
rely on people that you knew you rely on
other politicians to give you answers
and you find out that they are rhinos or
they gave you bad advice so we had some
that weren't good but when you think
Comey had a term he had many years left
in that term I said this guy's bad news
I realized it very early very early in
the administration I fired him and it
was wild that's when we found out all of
the corruption had I not fired Comey you
wouldn't know any of the things that you
were talking about you think they would
have destroyed you well they were trying
to take me out yeah they were trying to
take me out I mean it was like a coup it
was like a coup had I not you know it's
very interesting some people that are
very smart that you know very well
said when I did it oh that was a mistake
that was a mistake you're going to cause
now they say it was the greatest
instinctual move they've ever seen
because Comey was a very bad guy and
Comey LED that group of thugs in there
and they were doing a number they were
it's very dishonest it's years and years
of putting in people Democrats and
rhinos and other people but putting them
into office and we got rid of a lot of
them but we're going to get rid of a lot
more a lot more because you have some
bad food one more question I guess
in the past
[Music]
hey I'm like you I think we should have
paper ballot same-day voting make
Election Day a national holiday
and have partisan observers in every
Precision watching the voters and then
watching the vote counting and when the
polls close declare a winner game over
right but that's not the system we have
Republicans have been reluctant and
resisted towards early voting mail-in
voting and it and they've also been
resistant towards legal ballot
harvesting which Democrats have mastered
which is why they can hide in their
basement run hundreds of millions of
dollars in ads and and never answer a
press question or shake a hand or kiss a
baby or do a town hall my question is do
you now encourage and embrace early and
voting voting by mail and legal ballot
harvesting I do but I also have to say
something else because the one thing a
lot of people but this is important
including you don't talk about they also
create phony ballots and that's a real
problem that's my opinion what they
created a lot of money ballots has your
mind shifted in other words I think if
Republicans start out election day down
200 300 500 000 votes that's that
becomes nearly impossible to catch up
with for some reason Republicans always
wanted to go out on Tuesday and they
wanted to vote I respect that I think
it's great and it would be great if we
could get back to one day and we all the
things that you said
with you with voter ID with voter ID
because the Democrats don't signature
verification how about this they don't
want voter ID because they want to cheat
you know they want to cheat they don't
want voter ID even the Democrats regular
Democrat people want voter ID but the
leaders don't because they can't cheat
the one thing we have to be very careful
of is phony ballots everything you say
is great but they create balance that's
my opinion and that's the opinion of a
lot of people will you encourage your
voters based on the system we have to go
along with the system of early voting
and voting by mail because I think if
you don't it's a big mistake oh no no I
will but those ballots get lost also
Sean you know they send them in and all
of a sudden they're gone those ballots
get lost also the answer is I will
because you would like it but you know
what can I be honest for me okay but a
lot I got to take a break but Sean a lot
of bad things happen to those ballots
also they're sent in early and all of a
sudden where are they bet look we have
very corrupt elections we have no
borders if you don't have borders and if
you don't have good elections you don't
have a country and that's where we are
but I'm okay by the end of by the end of
this year we'll probably have under Joe
Biden nearly 8 million illegal
immigrants since he's been president
quick break hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else